see now the weekend is here and if
you're planning to eat out why not dine
with a purpose The Forum Shops is
hosting their second annual dine with
the purpose benefiting The Three Square
Food Bank and we have we have will
excuse me will Edwards here with three
square and Maureen with the Forum Shops
to tell us more how are you guys doing
great great thank you for having us of
course we love to have three Square here
because it's such a you know such an
important part of our community so let's
just start with you well
um you know it's hunger action month
what is the mission so uh hunger action
month
food banks all over the nation are
looking to raise awareness about hunger
in their communities and we do the same
thing here we want to get people to come
out
figure out what they can do how they can
help how we can solve this problem and
if they want to know they can go to
3square.org backslash ham to find out
all the things that are happening this
month perfect perfect and one of the
things is done with the purpose at The
Forum shop so Marine I'll bring you in
you know how will dine with the purpose
help this cause you know it's it's just
one of those great opportunities to be
able to partner with three square and
fortunately it is our second annual and
we feel like we've kind of got some
momentum going from last year last year
we were able to work with some of our
fabulous restaurants that are
participating again this year and we
were able to serve meals for 12 500
approximately people in the in the
community and so we're hoping to of
course you know you raise the bar and
the bar needs to go a little bit higher
this year so
um yeah it's just it's just a wonderful
opportunity to partner with will and his
team and you know get behind community
and yeah absolutely and there's eight
restaurants at The Forum Shops that are
participating can you give us a little
taste of what we're eating with the
purpose here yeah so we're fortunate
enough to have RPM Italian which is new
to the Forum Shops just recently opened
Joe's True Food Kitchen
um sushiroku
treve Water Grill the Palm Carmines and
all of them have selected meals that
they think are going to be well received
by the community okay and highlighted
dish right yes okay absolutely and um
and very well priced so the price points
can be affordable but yet the the
benefits can go to Three Square oh
beautiful and three Square will you know
these eight participating restaurants
will be helping you what will you do
with this money or the proceeds that go
to you from the highlighted dishes well
there is almost 341
000 individuals in southern Nevada who
struggle with Hunger so whatever comes
to ours it is going to really help our
community exponentially because every
one dollar that's donated we can provide
three meals wow so that's good that is
like that's the that's the ticket right
there right there thank you so much will
and Marine we appreciate you dying with
the purpose you all are going out this
weekend do it for the purpose you can't